sin duda es la gran crítica y la gran
contradicción por un lado Harry dice
estar obsesionado con proteger la
intimidad de su familia Pero por otro
lado prácticamente abierto Las puertas
de sus secretos más íntimos
probablemente algunos innecesarios al
público masivo en esta autobiografía
estas memorias Spear que en las que da
también agradecimientos a los lectores
por escuchar su versión de la historia
pero Harry no solamente sus memorias
sino también en las entrevistas que ha
dado para promocionarlas ha sido
recurrente en criticar el cubrimiento de
la prensa por especialmente de los
tabloides que lo han perseguido desde
que es muy pequeño pero también Harry
pone sobre la mesa esa relación de mutua
necesidad entre la familia real y los
tabloides los periódicos necesitan a los
Royals para que poseen y sonrían para
poder vender ejemplares pero la familia
real también los necesita para poder
mantenerse vigentes ante el público